we're excited to have chevy as our
sponsor tonight's show oh wow with
chevy's new line of electric vehicles
including the bolt ev the first ever
silverado ev and coming soon the equinox
ev guess what my favorite car name ever
truck name everett silverado that's good
they must have when they realize no one
else had taken that name they must have
high fived each other until they all
died
so these are the electric ones that's
right it's their whole line of new
electric vehicles and they are at the
forefront of innovation well let me
first of all i think uh yes they are
innovating i think we could innovate as
well
how so i think we need to be drastically
innovating
constantly
on the podcast to make sure that we
change and grow and stay ahead of our
audience what do you suggest i think i
should
you should surprise me with a wild
animal in the middle of every episode
not a large bear but a young bear that's
not as quite as strong as me but could
still hurt me okay and you just launch
it at me
halfway through the podcast and i have
to fight it i have to fight an animal
or a mountain lion or a bobcat and
people would hear that and they would
wonder every week yeah i like jeff
goldblum i'll listen to jeff goldblum or
yeah you know mullany i listen to
mullany or you know tignerterro i want
to hear this take no tarot wait a minute
i want to wait and see what animal they
throw on conan oh that he has to fight
off there's a real chance that you could
die i was gonna say you would die the
first time we did it you can't fight
animals like no what are you saying yes
he can oh sorry yeah that's a good idea
no no come on no i'm serious sorry i
don't mean to interrupt but i'm actually
getting some information that that
there's more info to be had on chevy and
it comes from one of our producers here
that we're not really getting to the
nitty-gritty like we should have so
let's bring that personality all right
as a producer i guess yeah
well if it isn't jordan schlansky
jordan you have something you want to
say about the podcast yeah listen this
is an advertising segment and rather
than promoting your own self-interest
your simple assignment was to mention
that after a hundred years of innovation
chevrolet has taken some of their most
popular vehicle models and made electric
versions and it's all based on their
ultim battery or in the original latin
pronunciation ultim and in fact
that's just not true in fact
the ancient romans who spoke latin and
favored innovation themselves would
likely have appreciated the extended
range of these vehicles because like
chevrolet in 80 countries the ancient
roman empire covered a lot of area
centered of course around rome in the
coliseum or as it was known back then
the amphitheatrum
and you
why does it always go to italy it always
goes to italy wow
why
okay we'll be talking about anything and
we're in italy within eight minutes you
in particular should be thankful for the
idea of innovation because if we were
still living in the roman empire your
desperate needs for attention would
likely have found you fed to the wild
animals in the amphitheater oh that's
what you're after that's my dream now
while i myself as a deep thinker and
philosopher would likely have flourished
and spent my days eating large
quantities of kacho a pepe pasta one of
the four famous roman pastas along with
carbonara amatriciana and grisha now the
key to properly preparing those pastas
is the use of the starchy pasta water as
the italians call amido and in fact all
of those roman dishes use pecorino
romano cheese which is made from sheep's
milk and those sheep are fed grass
leading to a higher nutritional content
specifically in the area of conjugated
linoleic acid omega-3 fatty acids
[Applause]
you're about to be tackled by my
security
[Laughter]
jordan i miss you i guess i love you if
you're a real person jordan schlansky
thank you very much everybody
[Applause]